and in pacifica
well pacifica is still pacifica
this has been your man stan join me for
another day in our city of dreams
so
welcome back my guest tonight is
lieutenant sarah kakoski spokeswoman for
the ncpd
hi there welcome to the show uh hello
ziggy
thanks for having me i hope you made it
to the studio without any issues
no carjackings or drive-bys along the
way
fortunately the streets of night city
are getting safer
every day we've seen recorded homicides
dropped from
7103 a year ago to
just hold on hold on
the streets are safe you said what about
the highways
well the ncpd is responsible for the
safety and security of all citizens
within
city limits but uh group one
sarah sarah sweetheart don't feed us
some
ncpd script be honest with your viewers
when will they finally be safe when will
they no longer need to carry a concealed
weapon for a trip to the mall
or to take their kids to play ball in
the park
the ncpd is doing everything it can
look at that cops
hello [ __ ] green screen
seeing if this looks any better
oh yeah i always i always stop the
[ __ ] streams like
mid an important mission for whatever
reason
cringe right
of which have you guys recovered from
yesterday's
super awkward right
all right just two seconds and i'm done
what's happening here
i'm trying to move the window there we
go
yeah back at it again boy
oh where's she doing
did i die here definitely set up shop
here
i see they must have hellman locked up
somewhere
buffy see that the pumps look pretty
good
not what you would find oh yeah i blew
up because someone shot one of the
gasoline
that's that's right good thing i'm self
master 64 as you can don't shoot
don't shoot the barrel don't shoot the
barrel
oh [ __ ] oh yeah the legs we're going for
legs
we're doing a full-on leg play-through
there we go
dude this oh god is that a drone
weapon lost all its power we need a new
one
leg
it is they're mine
because i'm on oh [ __ ] where the [ __ ] do
they come from oh god i'm dead
ah these random ass explosions
what blew up there seriously
[ __ ] barrels
is there anything to protect me from
explosions
uh yeah i think i saw the rewind thing
on
on the reddit
what is happening there's mines am i
stepping on mines
what am i missing here
why do i keep blowing up i didn't
what happened
sir what why do i keep blowing up
drones patrols definitely set up shop
here
uh they must have been locked up
somewhere
buffy see that the pumps look pretty
good
not what you would find if the place
were closed yes i'm supposed to just
shoot these
look at that so much damage are they the
one that shoot me
confuse swedish noises right now see
this is even worse than before
oh it's the snipers i got me okay
now at least i know the issue gotcha
i thought i exploded well this is a
great start
all right all right all right see if i
was allowed to play this the way i want
it
i would just drive this in they don't
let me
because i i'm doing the melee build
right so i just need to call it
close quarters and [ __ ] we'll try this
way stop here
i see they must have hellman locked up
somewhere
buffy see that the pumps look pretty
good
not what you would find they look pretty
good the bastards might have managed to
call for transport
all right enough someone sees me
impossible i am 100 stealth
right now
drone more like you're gone
[ __ ]
all right snipers can't get me now
[Music]
they say shoot but who
let's take out these sniper [ __ ]
oh don't shoot keep it small
hee yes
what the [ __ ] is this through the it's
jody through the wall again
that's cheating only i can do that bro
[Laughter]
bro why you do that
looks like this table turning
oh that did no damage shoot him in the
knee
do i take out those with with another
weapon
handgun nope nope absolutely not
all right we'll try this where is it
nope
is it dead is it dead
yeah alright does someone oh
[ __ ]
and everyone inside
nice
you didn't see me baby right i didn't
see you what the [ __ ]
healing leg
leg thank you am imagine dying by
legs [ __ ] cringe
oh oh
come on
all right who's like who's left next
with
lex i may invent new words now
[ __ ] is this
why are they shooting
am i blind
map says there's people there oh we're
way closer
[ __ ] i love the snipers so good
he can't hit me from here
uh guys you can't say simp anymore you
get banned
i just heard this morning that twitch is
banning sin
oh god 2020
what a time to be alive you can't say
that because it's a
is why uh
you just can't say it
yo people dog on youtube at least they
don't ban
pop culture words what the [ __ ]
sorry about your head bro
it's also weird banning simp now because
it's like a dead meme
it's for so long
oops don't move your head all right
all right you're done you're done leg
hand them over sir
leg tanks collection
thank you
freedom of speech yeah but not freedom
of consequence
are we done here
i mean see this is the problem i
i always do all this work and then i die
from like one stupid little mob
leg hand them over thank you
see what the [ __ ] was that
oh i don't know what that is
what's shooting me
i can't shoot it when it's down
is it still active no it's dead okay
well someone see me
didn't see me oops
come on just die
is there more
imagine dying like that cringe
he's like take my arm not my legs please
oh hell yeah
the [ __ ] is that a burrito
someone else spot me again
yo milk
see upstairs
damn no good loot huh all that for
nothing
oh there's more people
you haven't found a fan in him either
[ __ ] doesn't know who to be
scared of more you are a
sucker
[Music]
not a fan i take it i already said you
haven't
what's happening huh don't take this
personally
[Laughter]
he's fine a little buddy slap
and you shame
just remember you have helmet and that's
one hell of a card
try to win something sakura saved my
life remember
because it was in his [ __ ] interest
to do so still
just biz he's no friend of yours
sakamoro good news oh wow i didn't
realize how bad the green screen was
what did
he say live not too talkative now
taking him to the sunset motel i will
come to you
i can totally see the frame see
oh
it's nighttime
better take them somewhere you can talk
in peace true
thanks for making me do all the work
guys appreciate it look at this [ __ ]
guy
scooter ah you just come here
after i'm done
long story not sure even know where to
start
tell me next time
everything's done here all clear it's
charlie critical
live thanks to you thanks to v and pan
am they both saved my ass i just hope it
was worth it
that's all i tried to race for
maybe i could help out somehow i think
you've helped enough
i tried to stop him sure
just turn around now let it all be
damned you're good at that aren't you
it wasn't pan am's fault it really
wasn't pan
you and me are not buddy buddy besides
nobody's blamed anyone for anything
yet right was just helping me
it was my doing my fault that avg a
[ __ ] scooter
without me scorping his people wouldn't
have gone out he hates it here
that's the truth when you're an
aldocaldo you were always responsible
for yourself
and your people the circumstances change
nothing
perhaps pan am should ask herself if
she's still an aldecaldo
hey don't worry about saul we'll get
over it
as soon as he heard what had happened he
ordered us to follow him he was worried
something would happen
that was his look maybe you two don't
see eye to eye at the moment but your
family and saul will do anything for
family
the thing is am i even part of the
family anymore
you know you are come back to us
i understand
sorry you had to witness that things
just get
complicated dramatic sometimes
but and you
you look out for yourself all right
are we done this is our goodbye i think
that's it
until next time they're coming you got a
minute oh there's more
until next time take care of scorpion's
bike
it's yours now oh thank you hey we got
another bike bros
look at that
am i gonna sit on top of him
oh it's [ __ ] slapping time
hey joe
where am i what is this place let's cut
to the chase talk about your little
invention
biochip you made for our soccer fine
but let's get one thing straight first
yoruba arisaka didn't
send you no this means you must have an
offer for me
if your boss will pay more than kang tao
i believe we can talk
i got no offer [ __ ] understand me there
is no offer
what do you want
got silver hands construct in my head
it's literally driving me crazy and i
know it's only gonna get worse
that is unless i remove it and that
none of that's on the billboards i saw
not even
constructed that's impossible no he's
right there bro
it's moist critical again you have to
remove the biochip from my system
it's not that simple look you made the
thing didn't you
so where's the problem if you're telling
the truth you slotted in a new
experimental version of the biochip
y'all came here from the discord
notification how's the
it's got a different engram something
more
aware aggressive the bio chip is what's
unique not silver hands engram
the previous version of the chip was
only used to communicate with pre-safety
rarest [ __ ] cost a fortune yeah this
one's rarer
meant to install and activate the engram
in a new body
when i left arisaka the project was
still in the trial phase
huh imagine my luck to be so [ __ ]
unique
so [ __ ] exceptional that mean you'll
help me well well
i would have to see it first
okay
yo you can see keanu reeves now
unbelievable it looks like
i can't believe this suits the one who's
gonna help us
man i wish kiana was like a side
at least like a main quest headley yeah
i couldn't get to play with him
it was cool playing as him that one
five-minute segment
impressive isn't it but he's just
hanging around being an [ __ ] you know
i wish we were brewing it out
yeah real shame you could have been his
guinea pig too
tell me how to get rid of it
i'm afraid i have bad news your neural
network has completely deteriorated
it can no longer function independently
of the chip
the only thing
[Music]
ah not sweden
oh god please anything
is going on in my head sir there's got
to be another solution
what's it like to have two personalities
he's an [ __ ] because it's not like
you're hearing voices
you are both yourself and silver hand
simultaneously
i'm here to talk philosophy you want to
talk philosophy
i can see him and talk to him
you're not talking but yes i understand
what you mean
have you noticed the construct's
influence on your decision sweden still
exists
2077 doubt
what do you mean you will start doing
things that were once unthinkable
at least to your old self and you know
exactly who he was
a fanatic a terrorist a suicide well
[ __ ] me who's trying to mess with your
head can you imagine cyberpunk sweden
what the [ __ ] is that how does that look
like yeah i'm thinking dude
at least johnny never [ __ ] himself out
like you wait game audio come with me to
kangto
i'll try doesn't it just isn't going to
cut it sweden punk 2077
buy your way in with the chinese at my
expense do you even realize how much
data is in your head even if i can't
help you
the data must be saved well kang tao
offered quite the sum for it
you got it with you he's got to go
[ __ ]
did he go down stream back
what happened takamura
what the hell is he doing here yeah what
the [ __ ] he's got a few questions of his
own for you
you play nice he might even save your
ass
i'm almost done the blueprints
better than nothing you know when they
have like really tiny texts i always
wonder how they come up with that [ __ ]
like
in ssg2 they're just like
ah that sounds cool
he's all yours i'll give you two some
space
i hope we can come to an understanding
that is certainly in your best
interest v
i will remember this
okay how about i do this i turn down i
turn up
sons of [ __ ]
whatever you gotta say say it i wanna
talk to kiana got something eaten at
your code
that's clear been trying to learn how
you're wired this whole time
to know who i'm dealing with
thought you were just unlucky at first
but i kept
watching and finally realized what your
problem is
you were a kid from the badlands family
was your crutch and cr
but an nc and you're crutching best you
can do is steal from scam
you seem to know a lot about my past
well
seeing flashes of your past just like
you've seen
flashes of mine oh god did you see that
one time
in third grade when i [ __ ] in the shower
don't think i care what does interest me
is why you're a clingy creep
i think we can work together v but your
plans make no
sense destroy arasaka i
i don't even know what that means all in
good time
let's get out of here whoa you don't
know what you really what is happening
so you concocted a boogie man to fight
so glitchy the dialogue huh
you're funny
got a new life you did you got exactly
let's press him a bit maybe he'll open
up honestly don't differ a bit from
those poor bastards handcuffed to the
feeders in their mega block pads
oh now i feel like a dick i'll tell you
why i want to destroy our osaka but i'll
only tell you once
want to hear it all right
i saw a corpse strip farmers of water
and eventually of land
saw them transform night city into a
machine
fueled by people's crushed spirits
broken dreams and empty pockets
yeah what else corpse have long
controlled our lives
taken lots and now they're after our
souls
sure i'll go along can't really argue
with you there
v i've declared war not because
capitalisms are thorn in my
side or out of nostalgia for an america
gone by
this war is a people's war against a
system that spiraled out our control
it's a war against the [ __ ] forces of
entropy
understand whoa
do whatever it takes to stop him defeat
him gut him
if i got a kill i'll kill if i need your
body i'll
[ __ ] take it damn charlie
chill bro [ __ ] hell
you still don't see it but you will one
day
capisce
i love the italian word capisce because
it sounds like a whip or some [ __ ]
that's how they should say
i want to change my fob
video
vsync enable synchronized game right
with your monitor
why have i not done this
okay so
where's fob
ray tracing on
yeah yeah
feel the view it's so it's maxed
but it's so tight to my face
does that say
that looks nice
does that like for you guys because
a little choppier
shouldn't be
ripped frame per second yeah
yeah that's way choppier
[ __ ] ray tracing huh
that's better
yeah we'll run this it's a good job
i want rain tracing
[ __ ] it
how about this
there you go hey can i
and i borrow your car i'll hand it back
to you okay
what's going on here
oh [ __ ] they hate me like leg attacks
oh god what the [ __ ] i didn't do
anything
i didn't do anything i'm innocent
leg attacks hand it over
[Music]
like tax
[ __ ] i failed the light tax
[Music]
brought a sword to a gunfight
all right time for another jog
are they gone now that's a shame
all right let me call my car we got a
new bike now
jackets is way cooler come on
oh panam texted us hey i've been
thinking a lot about things and about
the [ __ ] we saw
okay okay
this is how you get girls guys this is
how you text them
um really helpful next time can you just
say you
she'll be back trust me
i watch my bike
oh here they are again what the [ __ ]
happened
what are they speaking
[Music]
that's for why why is my thing
whoa he [ __ ] teleported
[Music]
what the hell
jesus they're super strong this makes me
want to kill them even more
hey don't hit me
okay all right so a second chance
oh if their skulls are too strong
not for me all right
net for me
[Music]
why is it why is this thing like
shaking like a [ __ ] did i change
some settings
they didn't use a change like that
look at it you're laying with it now
all right leg pack turn it over
oh okay they might be too strong i have
i admit defeat
yeah but i used the gun before and it
was no problem
i'm so confused
am i hungry is that why low blood sugar
[Music]
okay
yeah i hear this game is [ __ ] on the
console look at that 45 damage let's go
maybe in a couple years i'll kill them
that looks nice
oh [ __ ] they're coming [ __ ] run
ah what the [ __ ] he's cheating dude
oh oh oh
hello
uh they're too scared
they're afraid look at him
[Music]
standing still did he glitch out
shoot him in the ass oh amazing
i told you i'm pro
it's going to take my whole mag
did he glitch out
can i go closer to him
hello he got me pinned
yeah i got you pinned down sir you
better watch out cuz i'm gonna get ya
[Music]
[Laughter]
i got you pinned down sir oh
isn't this annoying cover me oh
[Music]
just stand still trust me trust me
you're fine i'm covering you don't worry
you need cover i got you just don't use
the shotgun because i'll die instantly
and i will
oh that sucks to be dead [ __ ]
[Music]
ah i should stop i don't know why
this stuff is funny to me
there you go oh i'm wrong wrong bike but
i'll i'll take it
[Music]
all right let's keep moving
i won't [ __ ] with those guys anymore
they're clearly too dangerous for me
i don't want to i don't [ __ ] around
with that they're too strong for me i i
won't go near them
so anyway back to the city
oh [ __ ] i took the wrong turn
turn on dlss all right if you tell me
first
where in the settings it is and why
every time you tell me to do something i
go out and i look and i'm like where the
[ __ ] is it and i spend five minutes in
the settings
what the [ __ ] is the gps dude
[Music]
you never know where to go because it's
so cropped in
[Music]
oh god i hate the mini man it's so bad
man we're going fast
the [ __ ] sorry i wanted to go to wait
dream
damn this looks sick
[Music]
i keep missing the turn
thanks fanny pack huh
you buy it in the fanny store hello
hand it over
i'm asking who your husband is actually
who are you i'd rather not discuss
details over the phone
please meet with us we'll explain
everything
as i said it's a rather delicate matter
out of my way what's so delicate
i'd rather discuss that in person if you
don't mind
can we meet sure let's do that
i'll send you the address see you
johnny
[Music]
keep missing the turns guys
prime where
[Music]
whoa whoa whoa oh it's excellent it's
going great
oh this is oh this is amazing
[Music]
oh oh no oh no sorry
oh no why are you running
oh [ __ ] i should have done that
neutralize the criminals to receive your
reward okay i'll fight
i'll find the criminal guys don't worry
[Music]
must have gone this way
on my neck
oh his neck man they'll never find me
here
you okay there
you're right there having a [ __ ] in the
shower
i feel you
i look like a man whose last best hope
is a stroke of good fortune
yes all right i truly think so fortune
is like a roulette wheel
sometimes all it takes is a little push
this game is outstanding
main job mr hands or takamura
wait a day so we got a day to do
whatever we want perhaps you have a
point
i appreciate this advice hey
you're looking for some company tonight
well you found it baby
oh come on you can't kill hookers
okay violence against women is not funny
i apologize
hey if anything guys can be hookers too
what happened to my bike who [ __ ] with
my bike who [ __ ] with my bike
we did this
we did this oh now it works
he [ __ ] t post stopped here
stops
do it again yeah
[Laughter]
yeah he keeps doing it
[ __ ] yeah deep pose man follow him
who [ __ ] with i can't try it doesn't
drive anymore
come back t-pose man off get off get up
chase him chase him can't let him get
away he approached bang
he approached me stop it come back come
back back come back come back
i want to talk to you hey hey stop stop
running
i'm running i'm ready
what no ah
damn it all right you'll pay for this
you made p post man
[Music]
disappear
unbelievable
[Music]
all right there's gonna be attacks on
this one
legs and a molar stir
[Music]
nice
all right where did like mango tell me
now or
face consequence
i'll find him
i'll get to him one day
[Music]
[ __ ] i miss him
he was like father to me
[Music]
all right maybe now we can call this
bike
oh a bandana that might look cool
oh we have this cool i like that
now it looks better than the match
now that's too that's too mad maxie
[Music]
oh i like that
cool
i should use this one
[Music]
i'll just try some [ __ ] that's a muzzle
ever shotgun
[Music]
okay this is way better
i guess enjoying this this is a
highlight
oh oh
sexy
that's kind of cool
it will place a bounty on me i didn't do
that
[Music]
v how are you doing honey good got the
golden opportunity for you
okay on the streets that when waco says
golden
it's usually a turd wrapped in crepe
paper it's a
sticky situation
so what's the spec caroline jablonski
set off any puzzles whoa i didn't see
that murdered in cold blood
made waves a few years back they locked
the guy up
but now there's a chance he could walk
jablonski's family wants to balance
jablinski in this game
that's awesome you'll finish him
the purpose i'll kill a guy meaning he
deserves to die
truly do i look like a criminal
prosecutor to you
what did he do exactly i'm not a beat
reporter neither
you want the job or not take it all
right i'm in
good clients will be waiting for you by
a car at the corner at sixth and london
that far in the car
client wants to tag along be there in
person when you put a bullet through the
guy's eye
good luck what about his legs
can i keep them
should i turn it on or on
that one's a little better doesn't it
where's my bike i swear i called this
hello
gotcha
oh something happening here
[Music]
i like this gun
oh i like this guy oh she's alive great
no no don't
[Music]
don't go those are fine legs
end them over nice
you okay bro
[Music]
we're gonna talk okay
you know just gonna talk we'll
we'll takaroo i'm not gonna kill you
but what if we kiss in cafeteria
how did that sound hey don't fall
hey don't fight back what's wrong with
you
don't ever fight back the [ __ ] is wrong
with me
[Music]
okay hey there's my bike
who once abandoned his silver spoon
all right guess we do a side job sit and
wait no thanks
[Music]
look if a job meeting point where
okay that's not too far
i dare you to name a better candidate
for the world's gun runner in general
[ __ ] this thing stairs yo
whoa and it bounces
like bounce bam i could rip it a little
bit
[Music]
uh i need to turn here thank you we
watch you around eight years we want to
say thanks
thank you
hell yeah appreciate you
it's weird how much i like these random
moments on the bike within a bright
music playing
here we go hey hey are you v
it's me please step in the vehicle
you're not gonna check me or something i
was enough
hello v i'm jefferson perales
you've already spoken with elizabeth my
wife
so what do you got for me
carter let's go straight to the matter
at hand huh
i mean i guess we could chat up the
weather or debate where they served the
best ramen
to me but
fair enough business it is
elizabeth well as you're probably aware
mayor we want to know how
why whatever else is pregnant
far as i know case is closed already it
is
of course the police wrote it off as
natural causes
ryan passed it home due to a cardio
implant malfunction
but we're left wondering about the cyber
psycho attack city hall
a few days earlier the police say it was
completely
makes unrelated think the cops got it
wrong got any evidence
shortly before that patrick bateman he
made cuts in the ncpd budget
perhaps got on someone's bad side that
way
in any case we have a cyber psycho
attack on a bd
our chief of security scanned it but
didn't find anything out of the ordinary
so to speak
we need a brain dance editor a real one
it's wrong
no i hate the brain brain dance it has
to be back where it belongs today
where a lot of people will be in a lot
of trouble
if you agree to help you can see it
right now
sure all right see what i could do
excellent this game makes you motion
safe happy with any
it's my favorite the non-gameplay
gameplay
oh bro your jaw man well what do we got
here
question is what are you doing here
my brain too isn't it
[ __ ] chin dude don't go scrolling
every ass you see
eyes on the mirror stuff belongs to city
hall
let's make it pg okay
all right we got something to analyze
here
this is the whole guy no idea those ass
clowns are all the same
all right and then we have some audio
second conference in three days no idea
what this blitz is for
that's why i'm mayor and you're not
now's when we need the visibility
you're spreading yourself too thin i'll
rest
tonight my room at the red queen's race
is ready
yes of course good now go
change the layer i can't do it red
queen's race
cause any inner synap zaps fairy on
pants reference
really some powdered wigs shouting off
with their heads
you know you're allowed to say you don't
have a clue
hey
do people like this stuff they left
literally seconds before the attack
and it looks planned like it was done on
purpose
i think if it was a detective type of
game then it would be cool
don't get paranoid on me this doesn't
really fit in my opinion
[Music]
hold it stop right there
slow your roll re-reward ncpd
police let him in let him wait it's
important
gotta speak to the mayor's chief of
security supreme
probably what happened body disappeared
from the morgue sight unseen
and then some pig got himself a new set
of wheels in an ugly ass suit
luckily we paused right before your ass
again
once you've seen all i've seen don't
need to know things oh he doesn't even
know
people are the same everywhere okay
it's coming at you guys
i remember there was an anime and i
forgot the name of it
but there was something about a guy that
has like
these type of mods in him i don't know i
don't remember if it was a skeleton
that could grow
he was very protective of a little girl
and in the end he goes full
on with it so i don't remember that
anime it was really
good i remember there's a
really funny frame where he just goes
like zero point no not ghosts in the
show
what am i supposed to be scanning here
everyone's saying dororo
yeah he sounds more like
i'm curious
no not inuyashi it's older it's like at
least at least 10 years old
it was a really sweet animal
no not dorado what the [ __ ] has no one
seen this
oh now i i have to know now
i have to know
mark said this is when we watch the
movie and she's like i know that actor
i need to know i can't keep watching
until i know where they're from
and now i'm doing the same thing
all these japanese names i can never
remember then
i'll find it i'll find it
so many animates unbelievable
i'll know it as soon as i see it
sorry if this is annoying i'm being
selfish
oh my god i can't find it this sucks
it's not dora stop saying that yeah
no
ah you guys are the worst
bro his skeleton comes out
he protects a young girl
at least 10 years old
but what's cool was that you never it
wasn't even though it was
kind of futuristic there was only small
elements of it i felt like
it wasn't super cyber funky or anything
which i kind of like no not
gay gig
have i have i only am i am i did i dream
of this anime does it not exist
we're gonna
ring kai no that's [ __ ] bleach [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
oh god what have i begun
what have i started
no not bangkok all right you know what
i'm gonna go through each and every one
and i'll find it all right it's not
pecan it's not bucking underneath the
car it's not
again maybe this could be this
could be this
i'm going to find it i'm going through
my anime list
thank god for anime list
it's not 8200 it's not juju
oh have you guys seen kadas
it's a movie and i remember when i came
out i was like holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
it probably looks bad now but when it
came out it was so [ __ ] good
have i found it found it couldn't i
a six-year-old student by day and a
dispute meditator by night
though kind-hearted impatient due to his
tragic past he has trained for years to
live on
now despite his unimposing appearance he
is a strong martial artist
who also possesses a strange power
while taking various jobs from play yeah
that i i really liked it
i wonder why no one liked it
[Music]
it looks so bad when i'm looking at it
now sorry
okay all right it's mystery solved thank
you
couldn't i we did it thanks for nothing
like like when you bang some chicken
sister later same night and it turns out
they're both
sisters of god that really happened to
you
no but it could have nice one keanu
probably that he was standing by to lick
ryan's butthole
pewdiepie anime hopefully soon
[Music]
don't recognize it tune what he's
humming
wouldn't call that a tune he's really
into it
[Music]
you just leaked the coco melon diss
track he had to be killed
was it kuda knight i said kudonai oh
yeah could i sorry
i watched too much anime man
it's a problem
[Music]
you're here fantastic
so anything am i so short oh see
i'm trying to uncrouch why am i
crouching
rather not jump to any conclusions
there's not much to go on
why am i crouching sure sure that's a
stop
cop who saved ryan know anything about
him
detective river ward check the side of
the line we worked a few cases together
you want to talk to him i'll put you in
touch
i i understand we'll catch up soon
you're here fantastic
great timing either has crazy good luck
or had a source
got good info fear looks real science
shut up
the game is completely gonna shut
anything else let us know we'll help
[Music]
crotch and felix hidden tambo
that's a sick ass car oh it's [ __ ]
flies do
all right so i guess we're doing this
now
uh-huh okay
don't skip leg bay guys this will happen
shut up this is not my pov
maybe if i get in a car and it'll stop
please i can't stop crouching
help me
that's what i get for stealing people's
legs
ah at least i'm free
from the restraints
call detective ward i don't really want
to do that
[Music]
okay
doesn't work to click on it
there's a lot of money from that quest
oh
ah cops better act cool
so fresh it wriggles in your mouth
[Music]
cops again barack better act cool
better better not make it fuzz
now
the information from okada very valuable
i also learned something through my own
efforts
we must meet will it be this time
trash processing plant deserted end card
station
in the south of japan town there is a
street bucket
nikora it is on a footbridge above the
main street
use the elevators oh it is easy to get
lost
i am on my way there do not make me
wait
oh okay guess it's time
what should we do
i like the main quest a lot more
but i also came all this [ __ ] way and
then you just call me i don't
[ __ ] know where which one listen this
[Music]
one
if sweden is in cyberpunk 2077 i just
imagine yeah siren head being
overrun the whole place i can't that's
the only future i see
oh purple item purple island
hey claire where do they go
you know your [ __ ] and you've got good
taste
meat beast my pride and joy
beer in the fridge if you want me thanks
so what's this about need a driver i
thought you might do
uh a driver huh good thing i'm an
excellent driver
not exactly this kind of racing involves
drivers
and gunners so you a turret guru
or a driver's ed out i'm more an engine
tuner
good at it too and i shoot but i'm no
rally racer
i trust you're capable behind the wheel
very low key stream today thanks for
hanging out guys
sure claire i'll be your driver
okay we got four races first one's in
city center
it should be easy by the badlands at
santo then watson to finish
when do we start there's a qualifying
ladder need a climate to reach the
finals
how high top three and at least two
rallies gets our ticket stamped
let's meet in city center i'll snap you
the specifics
you hear the roar of overtune monsters
that's the place see you there
can i loot the purple items now
i'm so confused is the car purple what
is that glitch
there is something here yes give me that
there was another one wasn't it
there is another
give me that [ __ ]
okay
guess we gotta wait a day anyway
um let's meet with mr takamura song
okay so now it'd be good to fast travel
there so if i click here
would it like tell me to
wait where am i oh i'm here i'm next to
a fast driver perfect
it's after this we go watch kur tonight
nice hold up
oh
v it's a good thing you answered i could
probably use your help
probably fine i could really use your
help
can we meet oh [ __ ] it's pam
yeah he's telling me when and where you
don't know how good it is to hear that
swing by the altical those camp i'll
explain it all
the cow though i thought you parted ways
she needs me it's a long story just
hurry over
i'm here
hole oh that's a nice car
no no no
i want your car
[Music]
all right we're done
is there an elevator
where is he taking me
is every ad like this
oh i keep thinking they're little people
hey how you doing
my daddy has a better job than your dad
oh you don't
[ __ ] know that do you [ __ ]
say that again
you're lucky you're a child
[Music]
dramaalert takes over 2077.
what kind of drama will they report in
why what are we doing here you shall
learn
soon
i acquired some information of my own
do you know for most wish to honor
arasaka
with the parade his murderer
the irony mix what
so there he is
my oh my look at him so handsome
it's a beautiful day huh
whoa
[Laughter]
hey you guys ever looked at your dog
when they don't know that they're being
watched it's
there's something really funny about it
it feels the same when you're looking at
the npcs
sure we continue still don't see how
this gets us anywhere
i have had an idea look to the sky
the dash flows will be damn this is
exactly this way
i can speak with high in private get
there how
why jump of course of course
expectations way too high goro couldn't
pull that off even if you still had your
fancy implants
i have thought of a solution while you
are occupied with your shady dealings
i learned more about the vlogs they are
all kept in one place
arasaka industrial park it is there that
they
prepare them we need only to break into
the compound
find the right float and inject a virus
into
its system you will then be able to
disable
any security before i sneak inside
lots of ways to skin this particular cat
damn i know what you need
it is taking care of i have an infected
shot
it was not a shadow but the man who sold
it to me guaranteed it will work
let us move on
are you liking those fries
could i have one
this is not a good time to panda life
you enjoying that
take control of the flood is one thing
you like that fry
the security concerns the snipers
especially
so good right be an easy target
but i may have an answer oh god as i
mentioned the city cabinet
it's a beautiful day we're gaining
access to them we will see
exactly where the snipers are you can
deal with them as i advance
oh you have the same tattoo that's sick
hey what's up what will i do now
yes jump
you said it you okay
don't do it you know life gives you
curveballs
but it'll be all right okay but we fine
i can't make it no don't say that
you can make it you made it this far
right
is that teddy fresh
give me another dialogue hey friends
you got style seriously ah thanks
welcome welcome thank you
mermaid sounds like a plan
you agree just like that the risks are
considerable
yeah well get more and more used to that
and now what would you say to a small
test
we must try the shot the camera control
room is
in front of us you must get inside and
infect the network
that is all uh-huh and in the meantime
you'll do what
crack open a can of suds i would not
touch alcohol at work
i will watch your back now get to it
yes
nice
[ __ ] worked
and done systems
that was fun i like that the shot works
good
the easy work we have done to break into
arasaka industrial park
will not be such a bed of roses but
before we discuss that
how's it going
good sit
i have not eaten since yesterday
give me the best on the menu
i highly recommend the yakitori today
anything that isn't local please
tomorrow
can't believe i'm saying this but this
soccer scum might actually prove
useful he's a well-trained dog needs
orders
that's all and when he outlives his
purpose
nice
he's not on his a-game sure even without
implants japanese meatballs easily
where's that come from everything
what is this he hasn't had a bite bro
oh he's gotta be pissed okay
i have laid the plan what was the point
we break into arasaka industrial park
one and a half
we have kanakos eat your [ __ ] food
during the parade with my help you
eliminate any snipers
three i get onto the float
four i convince hanakosama of the truth
hey look we got five oda zeros us
and pisses on our corpses he will never
be less than
a foot away from hanukkah although not
there raised his hand against
me what about me
that is a different matter i would
advise you to watch your distance
look just have a bite bro that easy
dude i had two and one
come on man just eat
you're gonna have yours or what
well sounds like a suicide run but don't
dumb as [ __ ] than this so
things are even more stupid than
stealing from arasaka
none dumber yet no set the bar pretty
high with that one
now we pot reconnaissance is required
agreed this we will do together
ultimately to defend the well-being of
my friends
do we call the murder of my father was
that not a provocation
was that another
an empire before your friends
from the inside all of this began
with him the factions
power struggles all of this
so why'd superior tolerate it all
can't get my head around it but kept the
sun on a short leash
arasaka was a strong and disciplined man
the strongest man i have ever known
and yet at the critical moment
he showed a weakness for your noble
for his daughter when you're in a
phone his bed of hounds declared
war on his own family
could have crushed him with one word
yet he did not for he did not
wish his daughter to suffer
when you're in a return his tail between
his
legs she persuaded hafada to give him a
second
chance do you understand
anakosama saved the urine from the
consequences of
his deeds
[Music]
feels like that's about to change as
long as we get hanukkah to believe our
version of events
conscience could also come into play
assuming she's got one
we must reach her first will you join me
i wonder if it itches it's got an itch
to have that right
and how do you shave around it
sure why not let us go from here
i hope you enjoyed it oh he loved it
what a mess dude jesus
sheesh louise i have found a good place
to observe okay
it says no entry though we can possibly
no we must just climb up here
are you crazy oh
no this way
found an alternate path
found the hidden route bro why am i like
this i'm sorry
surprise
that was your day you must be really
hungry
blood sugar low you should have a snack
protein bar will cheer you at
you know it's important to keep your
energy throughout the day
i would call this a beautiful view of
the city
if if if there was anything to admire
ate night city that much
perhaps i am simply homesick as you say
now you must look for vulnerabilities
weaknesses while i try to think of a
diversion
arasaka cannot discover our intentions a
bit of
sabotage it's just what we need to
divert
their intentions so many moments that
reminds me mayor's age and i i really
like those moments like
when you're in a part of a city that
you're not supposed to be and you can
look at on it there's so
it feels so atmospheric which i really
like
i think the like you can be in a city
that feels realistic but it feels better
almost when you're
outside of the city looking in this view
on the left
i will try here this old scope should be
good for something
shall we begin let's do this
let the scanning begin camouflage
turrets by the gate
[Music]
ah they got bro they got a
camouflage turds by the game
i do not wish to die here there we go
thank you
and then pipes see them
[Music]
we could use them to get inside
a little stealth mesh
security hub is liable to be in that
building
[Music]
okay so we should get in the building
get out the security go through the vent
cross no we're not doing that
[Music]
across the bridge hahaha [ __ ] british
means so cringe at this point i feel
[Music]
like am i looking at here
this
[Music]
looks like a service tunnel by the road
there
so actually more
it could lead to the warehouses
this is not bad
trucks drive up regularly uh
you know what you think i've seen
everything speaking of unfunny do you
know what you guys do
yes perfect full dodge every [ __ ]
video
or instagram post or [ __ ]
people just copy each other's comments
to get
upvotes it is what you said before
entering a competition
i wish to be certain and it's the it's
even comments are aren't related to the
video
but they still get upvoted and you just
scroll down and you just see the same
comments
and yes we go in then all right great
sounds sensible
better get comfy
it's so weird because it happens every
video and i'm like
why did why does this keep happening
[Music]
what it's so lame
those are the movements do you see it
that yet
yeah okay if they're bots but you even
get people calling huh the bots are here
or some stupid [ __ ] and then that fine
looking feline
thought they'd all disappeared from the
city
it is the first animal i see in night
except cockroaches of course it's not
just bonds
then dogs cats actually it's people
doing it as well
and you goddamn know it chill
just a cat perhaps
perhaps not
[Music]
miss home a foolish
question
i am from the slums of chiva 11
once when i was desperate to live there
i
bad memories washed away by time i
long only for the simple days of
childhood
should i share about my nomad past
childhood let's see
racing my bobber for the first time
through the hills
did i miss jack in the comments first
kiss in the middle of the synth
cornfield
i remember the chemical stench of the
canal
where we boys washed our shirts
corporate transporters sometimes passed
through our slum
arasaka selecting children but
only the clean ones you get that too
jack right on every video there's the
same people making the exact same
comments
and it's so unfunny
you can you can scroll down and see
three people make the same comment
everyone's saying it's bots but i don't
believe it's all bots i think it's
people desperate for attention
exactly when they chose me
i felt i had won the lottery
in the army i was given everything i
lacked before
discipling regular meals and when i
proved
i was gifted an education
all he had to do in return was kill
soboro's enemies
i sense that you judge me no i didn't
yet
you have no right to bro no unlike you
and your friend mr wealth
i was not around i did not take the easy
path
wasn't judging you and true you oppose
the corporations
their order their world in a mindless
way
yet you offer no worthy
take alternative look around it's here
your corporate world and its glorious
splendor
you shall be filthy streets as if no
other world
exists as if nothing else is possible
what of the millions of work for arasaka
and
receive stability save chiba 11 slum
rats
they're there scraping scraps out of
scoptines
corpse decided that too
we cannot fix everything at once
tired big grin let's just drop it yeah i
won't fight with you man
sometimes i wish to become a nomad to
leave this world
forget everything
never too late to change
what is your expression one cannot teach
an
old dog new tricks
do you know what i think yeah
that day we both have lost
someone important and we are not at
peace with this
so we seek conflict argue eagerly
i think you have an evening days that i
think that's the problem
don't be smart got no idea what i feel
it is the duty of the living to atone
for the dead
anakosama shall aid us in our mission
or shall make sure we die for good
the bakanenko
oh god it's so slow it's painfully slow
dude
i think it is time to do something
[Music]
oh [ __ ] get worse you do not look so bad
thanks
cozy
all right he's too slow
oh bro
it hurts come on
am i so impatient i don't think i am
cool maybe now you can have dialogue
when we're not actually doing anything
in an
elevator [ __ ]
it's so dumb
i'm just walking
cool
okay remember the mission now
real life simulator breaking their
okay steal the truck i want to do that
let's steal the roof
i should have stolen that [ __ ] uh is
this suspicious
hey guy it's totally me
[Laughter]
stealth hundred right there that's why
i'm here
very well i'll never expect
i'll be in their communication systems
but it's blog bro
[Music]
that set them off i barely nudged it
dude
all right
this [ __ ] blows
you see me
[Music]
i think i should just die and redo this
but
because they're very strong yeah let's
restart
sorry
[Music]
i love that
hold up a lot this is mine
don't tell anyone all right so this
doesn't set
off anyone but
i mean good now try to enter the
warehouse
yeah all right over there
rather clever that's why i'm here
very well i have raised the roof
i'll be in their communication system
soon
i got you oh
i need to go in here oh yeah that's the
building isn't it
thank you
[Music]
uh-huh
yeah can we come
okay one second
you come with me again
so it was a risk when you find some
chocolate on your trap
edges here
can you see him
yeah my man
okay someone done this mission
y'all walking me through it
am i supposed to stay in the truck
[Music]
it is amy
hey
it's impossible to see me
good
i'll make the system sick
right just redo it
i don't know where i am
[Music]
this is fine
nice gun
i don't know
yeah redo
[Music]
oh so if you hide again for a minute
they forget about you
stealth missions has never been my thing
i don't know if you guys notice this but
i'm kind of impatient
don't shoot the truck gets you in
[Music]
good now try to enter the warehouse
i will draw their attention away
rather clever
very well i am reasonable
i'll be in their communication systems
am i supposed to wait here
[Music]
oh that's weird i spotted something
a lamp
[Music]
no threat detected
no
here i got it i'll never find me
all right going good
was it the cam that gave me away
[Music]
copy your personality in grammar i mean
and you're looking good
now try to enter the warehouse i will
draw their attention away
rather clever that's why i'm here
very well i have them
i'll be in their communication systems
[Music]
geez louise
that's a big boy okay so i gotta
distract these guys
yo the fourth
that's crazy oh the camera
[Music]
there we go i mean
i just float they are controlled from
inside
[ __ ] quick save that [ __ ] it could
be an ordinary terminal
gotcha how's things at your end good
i the contour room and make a terrible
mess
very well i am ready
when you finish i'll make the system
sick
[Music]
we're gonna hack the float i don't have
the ability
this is so sad
[Music]
must be another way in
gotta loot all the garbage you know
someone left a
pig full on pizza savages
[Music]
camera there
anymore
much as i'm not for self it is
satisfying when it works
[ __ ] as soon as i said that
this guy does not want to be distracted
what is it now
oh no i got it it's gotta be quick
you can't see me they can't see me
they can't see me you just say they
can't see you
it actually helps
oh god geez that was close
[Music]
i am standing on top of the distraction
here let me try this
[Music]
you can't do that
hey worth a shot
maybe i should upgrade my hacking stuff
more
hey look forklift it's going crazy dude
doesn't give a [ __ ] whoa it's going down
now
oh that's that's crazy
that worked okay amazing
this guy's a little fuckeroo
oh now now now he you're like no it's
not supposed to do that
i kind of want to kill him
oh quiet
[Music]
schmackaroo let's get his gun
oh it's garbage all right
come with me big boy
[Music]
here
where did he go
[Music]
i am a wizard that's
so cool
i wonder if that will work again it's
okay
flow starts to do without a one-time
glitch fly to tokyo if you want
i just may do that now
it is my turn can you see there were
kills
even the roof is slowly me the roof
that is your wheel there are buildings
around
smaller ones he's going he's okay
[Music]
oh there he is
[Laughter]
found you where did you go
go that's so weird
oh someone said he got izakaya again
i did a non-lethal takedown and i
changed my mind
[Music]
let's check for luke
oh you could have climbed in here i knew
that
[Music]
all right back to stealth
look at this [ __ ]
you didn't see me
good call guys good call
[ __ ] worked [ __ ] amazing
[Music]
try not to get into any more trouble as
if i wasn't in enough already
i like that
so we did it oh we level up sir
sweet
what else do we got in the way of the
blade
what are these then oh that's high
oh so it goes
there and there or where the bleeding
i think we should go
[Music]
boom boom
why can't i pick that one
[Music]
20.
okay
blunt weapon that's like a baseball bat
right
is
oh that's actually good
it keeps stacking so after defeating an
enemy you get two percent movement speed
that's garbage
oh yeah ah
[ __ ]
let's do that
i think i can jump from here
bonus today
i hear snoring near
um
he's really out of me
t post now
[Music]
cute
bro you're wearing shorts okay and
what's your packing
on our street
what's so funny now
[Music]
it wasn't me
it wasn't me i swear
one more shot easy
no problem
hey guys there's a crazy guy on the
[Music]
loose
what
whoa f5
should i call mr hands it doesn't let me
there we go
what's shaking need to make contact with
the buddha boys
all right all right straight to heavy
business hmm
now that'll be memo brigitte be tough
getting the word into her
really don't do anything i hope he's
doing a video on cyberpunk
just hit me all got durable sized egos
won't talk to lowly people
so much goofing if you insist i can ask
around
try to set something up i'll just need
some details first
got something they want truly
want to sell something to the vdbs trust
me
they don't want it they don't need it
they're isolated insulated they got
their own contracts
tech networks but have it your way
okay i'll see what i can do and get back
[Music]
what am i doing here
okay they're telling me to do side
quests
guess we're meeting pan am
[Music]
mr hans is a celebrity cameo it's ninja
my mind will be below
we've seen those videos with that
i think they're arabs and they drive on
the freeway or highway and they just
they literally drive like this it's
[ __ ] nice
spoiler it was me
i supposed to go there
well it's like i said whatever you're
peddling the vdbs are just not in the
market
but they have another task that needs
doing so i volunteered you
v do it it's good you're here you'll get
your audience with bridges what happened
okay so what do i do
of kiana reeves comes in now i felt i
could count on you belong to a nomad
family too once
city doesn't change us all that much i
guess
that's hard to deny whatever goodwill
you might feel
i'm sure you won't turn down one of the
best sniper rifles on the west coast
you saw it in action already yes
okay now you're speaking my language
once you have it in hand
fancy all of a sudden becomes kick-ass
let's go
mitch will walk you through the details
watch me hit the moon on a perfect spin
look at that
because i've done so many face clan 360s
i know how to do pan m and it
what's going on there what's the
pewdiepie gamer mouse check out link in
the description
look how fast i can zoom on that tree
[Music]
you really aim to do this someone has to
you know you have a piston missing right
someone has to
yes what's up i want to see what you got
in stock
browse to your heart's content
thank you
what do i need for that packs one hell
of a kick level 22 i'm level 16
[ __ ] so i keep that around
wait i have two katanas
oh maybe not
still so poor where's mitch
i wasn't going to meet me [ __ ] off he'll
be here any minute
huh you never mentioned seeking outside
help
we can use all the help we can get
lean against the car okay how do you
want to do this
quietly and open this up
mitch is already setting up the recon
you'll sneak into the rates cam
while i cover you
going in quiet two's all you need it's
not that i don't want to go
to serve some raffins up some justice
it's just
look around the last attacks left barely
half of us standing
our supplies are stuck outside goddamn
reno and our gear
don't get me started we're up [ __ ] creek
static and i don't know the leader gets
nabbed and you
what hope for the best rather not think
about what you do for the ones at the
bottom of your food chain
you're asking for i want to see you
leave it he has a right not to
understand
there's mitch
floated a drone over the wraith's camp
will you take a look or would you rather
keep mouthing off
hey let's see what we got here the
raffins can't see it
active camo but that practically inhales
battery juice so make it quick
they found an abandoned cement plant to
squat in with a mass of heavy gear
locus would be a better name for them
they fly into a place
stripping of all its got then move on
but this time
do you see the wall they've added some
primitive security measures
it points to them aiming to stay longer
the question is why
who knows for sure but i would guess
that saul is part of the reason
if he's still there we have to find a
way inside
that guard post is probably connected to
the rest of the camp
maybe but there are also breaches in the
wall lightly guarded sections
oh
do you see the tracks
tire tracks their vehicles were moving
heavy freight
it could have been equipment either that
or saul's not their only prisoner
the tracks lead to the truck can you
scan it
no
that's probably the one that kept
stalling you're uncomfortable there
the main building there saul must be
inside
quite a spread it's like looking for a
diamond in the hailstorm
if they haven't scrapped and gutted the
place for parts you could access the
local cabinet
you would just need to find the control
room
this feels like a setup
yo
the skywalk it connects the garage to
the main structure
okay got some stuff to work with now
you know i'm just gonna go in blasting
taking my enemies with me
and if not they start so they will never
forgive me lord forgive the heavens
got me not knowing how to act
i did what i could take a tour
give me sniper now
please
solid job i mostly improvised actually
either way it'll have to do
hold on a minute i got one more thing if
you find saul hasn't flatlined you'll
probably need this
spike super jet a rhino dose it should
speed up saw central pump
sniper hope so doubt i could carry him
out of my back
so that should be everything v will you
ride with me
yeah of course i'm going with you okay
you take the wheel
one me driving yep i need to fiddle with
my scope a bit
it's sorry again it's my scope
oh it stopped oh yeah we even have a
radio in here
take it for a spin if you like
i like that song
where am i driving
those bars dude
[Music]
that's am i driving
two kilometers what the [ __ ] dude i
ain't got [ __ ] nine enough to fall
don't get on my diamond
dude i can't see anything
[Music]
let's go eat let's go bird uh
quicker right
i still can't believe he let himself get
captured
anyone else but saul said yourself he's
not at the top of his form
yes but we're fine moving civilians
across the border during a bombardment
hijacking a petrochem tanker opening the
valves
cranking a few figure eights to set the
desert ablaze and give the kids a fun
show that's the song i remember
all had our items i know
it's just
i love when you're driving with npc and
it's just like
they don't give a [ __ ]
you liking this
why is it saying it's over there
that's what she's saying do you think we
can make it
do you see that that is one hell of a
storm
oh that she's coming at him bad oh it's
bad and more than its look
we have to move quickly yeah that's what
i've been doing girl
okay let's go over the plan again you
slip into the rates cam
sucked as a fox this car sucks
i'll be your long-distance insurance
policy we'll be linked at all times
so as soon as you find saul i'll fire up
the engine and we'll speed up
mm-hmm
yes we're gonna make it brush
[Music]
we're gonna make it
you want to grab the wheel
i think he can do better
[Music]
okay out i'll find a place to roast okay
i feel sick after that
you just watch yourself down there oh 20
xp
yeah let's put another scope on this gun
real quick
more sniper ice fully type of deal
there you go
all right i'm in position i have you in
range
you can't see me
surprise [ __ ] non-lethal
as always no one dies on my playthrough
nice oh [ __ ]
[Music]
i don't know you can do that
[ __ ] down the system
does he see me right now
can i not you sit crouched
don't like this
keep your eyes peeled i see several
heavy hitters just wait
[Music]
anyway
it wasn't me
[Music]
oh i got poison
so anyway you started blasting
okay out i'll find a place to roost and
keep you in sight
you just want yourself down there okay
all right
back to stealth master 64.
broke my legs it's fine it happens
what am i looking at you sleeping
bro are you sleeping all right i'm in
position i have you enraged
donnelly where are the good guys
imagine waking up with no legs last
thing you
remember is the swedish stinky breath
wake up in a bathtub legs are missing
your arms are sweaty legs are missing
spaghetti already
i mean
legs hand them over right now
oh [ __ ] i did a lethal kill [ __ ]
okay you're near the main structure
you can't chop up their legs if you
already kill them
okay remind me to do non-lethal
[Music]
who keeps giving me money
don't move damn it stay out of sight i'm
trying
why she bitching
hey i'm working on a little pile over
here
gotta hide the body right
[Music]
the leg bandit strikes again
main building
i feel it in my bones remember what i
told you
find the control room and you'll gain
access to the security cams
i feel that in my legs that i have
no [ __ ] hey not lethal yeah
[Music]
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
what's he doing is he alive he's alive
it's a surprise
oh shoot i'm swedish legs
[Music]
thank you
what the [ __ ] dude you're gonna get me
killed
[Music]
just collecting taxes what's the big
deal
that's okay that's too correct
don't do that don't do that
[Music]
don't do that
whoa
i can't see my crosshair it's too bright
[Music]
stop
there a problem
[Music]
i shoot that
great
gotta get my asthma fixed
oh i should not
[Music]
is
let's not die now
pretty good self mission
i like it
and just hand them over
[Music]
cool i'm where i was before
did i just have to press that was that
it
fire [ __ ] skin melt [ __ ] yourself
[Music]
and so much more
limps not picky
[Music]
well now they won't see i'm coming
all right i'm an excellent hacker
[ __ ]
[Music]
i see green
all right we gotta find the soul guy
[Music]
you're in here buddy
who leaves a meal like that
oh purple
[Music]
nice
all right what am i missing
i did this
[Music]
if someone tell the game there's no
combat and they can stop playing the
[Music]
music
this one person outside yeah isn't it
where poor soul
yellow is that good
[Music]
where's the guy
where
[Music]
i should turn on the cams again
found him am i looking now
okay now it tells me
nothing personally
[Music]
yeah i thought i had no nudity on what
the [ __ ]
this did vowel and not just for a chrome
[ __ ] rabbit soulless belt
there's no light they won't cross
right i think i got eyes on i do man
[Music]
get out of here orange
orange orange
name a yellow fruit
where is it
she left not forever
[Music]
you i remember you're that murk
i was crafting pretty badly
probably
oh yeah so how is he time to don my
dancing shoes you'll live
don't get yourselves out of there middle
of a [ __ ] storm down here
brewing to be a category 5. i'll be
right there
brace yourself do you think new enemies
will have spawn
[Music]
damn it that's it you got strong legs
i'll give you that
[Music]
i thought
these are a lot stronger
chilling in the corner
[Music]
yeah all right
hope you guys learned something here
today never skip like that you're right
got a new mask
sick that's cool
oh we got an even harder one but we need
level 18.
got a new jacket looks pretty
flashy i i think i'll keep it
new pair of pantalonies
not as good but
no they're better
nice
ah what do we need 18.
everything's 18. i can't use anything
and you're making a mistake
another one you're serious right now
those devils wanted to know our location
if we drive to campus should just be
setting the table for them you look
outside
the stream what are you saying got to
record another video
and the scent of blood what we got more
chomping at our tail
[ __ ] but wait
yo we got a jurgen tattoo we need to
shake them
the three arrogance that's one way to
treat an engine
[ __ ] off saul damn you gonna let it talk
to you like that bruh
[Music]
oh this is hard
we got more bang
bang bang bang
[Music]
all right
got their driver
[Music]
they're still driving somehow okay
all right damn it that's it
we got hit i can't push it
i need me an angle
oh my god
thing dude
let me play i don't get the point of
that
i thought i thought cd probably red was
like
the gamer company right
they're the ones with the cool [ __ ]
you see those buildings we'll wait it
out there
i remember this place it should be safe
at least for now
i'm so skilled i took out two cars for
that shooting at them
yeah it's the same on every chase scene
i still like the game it's just like
small stupid stuff sometimes that it's
like
come on why
i need to catch my breath
it was all scale thank you oh another
mask
oh i love this game now
[ __ ] i hate this game
just in time for dinner not hungry
i just swallowed it i didn't even notice
my shots weren't hitting until the
eighth cut scene
nice looks like we're in for the night
a little power might be useful could you
help me look v
i'll search in here i make it look
scripted sorry
bro i actually really gotta go i don't a
lot of useful things
i'm not time to look in the mirror
hey we got this glitch again that's a
smile for the camera
okay guys thanks for watching another
epic let's play episode hope you had fun
i sure
did wrong way to get them out i'm bald
for no reason you end with nothing saul
don't go there not now
turn on the power they said
but it's [ __ ] pitch black
is it outside
oh there we go
i have a chance to fly with pan am here
oh okay
in front of the guy i like that i'll do
it just too
i tried to get us some heat in here no
luck
can you check it might have the magic
touch
actually you know what check the fuse
outside i'm not checking another [ __ ]
piece all right
edgar say goodbye
johnny bye bye
bye bye see you later
i had enough he plays too much video
games
uh so tired
oh careful
okay see you guys
hey boo
you